the spooky season is indeed upon us and
as always it kind of peaks with the
holiday of Halloween a really
interesting holiday that over the 20th
and 21st century has spread all over the
world and become really really popular
um in America it is actually the second
most popular holiday in the entire year
it's a season associated with everything
from ghosts witches zombies horror
movies uh parties and alcohol
trick-or-treating candy Charlie Brown
and much more and even though I'm not
that old um I can confirm that since I
was a kid it's been a major thing even
in Sweden you know Tri or-treating is
pretty big here Halloween has been
celebrated since well for a couple of
decades at least but what is Halloween
really there are often many theories and
claims being thrown around Christian
groups concerned about its practice
calling it Satanism and paganism people
being confused about its connection to
other celebrations such as All Saints
Day or Dia de Muertos in Central America
and much more the origins and
development of Halloween can be pretty
confusing but it is a really fascinating
story that can tell us a lot about how
these kinds of traditions and holidays
um develop and how religions and
cultures interact throughout history in
different ways to create some of the
most famous and popular festivals of the
year in this case so in this episode to
celebrate this year's Halloween we're
going to dive into the history and
development of this fascinating holiday
as we ask the question what indeed is
[Music]
Halloween
for most people Halloween falls on
October 31st each year on the calendar
this is right around the time when
things start to get darker when the
collar of the leaves have started
turning and they're falling to the
ground and there's a certain chill and
feeling to the Autumn air and it's no
coincidence that Halloween takes place
at this time of the year of course as
you will see most people trace the
origins of Halloween to an ancient
Celtic quote unquote Pagan festival
called
sawin and while this theory is most
likely true the history of the festival
is also much more complicated than that
we know very little about the ancient
Kelts and their Customs they didn't
really write things down and so all our
information is essentially based on
later Christian writers describing the
local quote unquote Pagan customs and
already here we have run into a major
problem since these Christian writers
Were Us usually pretty critical of local
customs and we're very much concerned
with discrediting it in in different
ways but that doesn't mean we have to
discard everything indeed much of what
Christian missionaries and writers have
reported elsewhere have turned out to be
somewhat accurate such as in the case of
the nostics for example and modern
scholarship is also increasingly
allowing us to get a better picture of
this fascinating pre-christian culture
sawin was the Celtic New Year an annual
Festival that marked the end of the
summer season and inaugurated the coming
winter it's a transitionary moment in
the calendar in other words and was
accompanied by various
celebrations because it was the end of
the Harvest crops were gathered
livestock was taken inside again and
some animals were slaughtered so the
year's summer Harvest was celebrated by
eating and probably drinking alcohol
which made the party pretty Rowdy there
are also reports that bonfires would
would be lit which would also involve
the quot unquote Priests of the Celtic
religion which were called jids so when
exactly did Sinn take place you guessed
it the celebration began at sunset on
October
31st the Kelts believed in a kind of
afterlife which they called the land of
Summer and sn/ October 31st was also
important in the sense that they
believed that on this day every year the
boundary between this world and the next
was broken temporarily which means that
spirits and other beings from the other
world could enter into this
one alongside these celebratory and
Rowdy aspect of the holiday there was
thus also a certain spooky and dangerous
vibe to it as well which could of course
be argued to have survived into modern
Halloween now sawin has often been very
misunderstood and
misrepresented it's true that it is a
pagan Festival but the word Pagan is a
derogatory term used by the Christians
to describe non-christians at this time
so that term should be used very
carefully and very sparingly but many
reports have indeed falsely depicted the
Kelts as being totally bloodthirsty evil
people that sacrificed human beings left
and right and did horrible things
especially during the sawin season now
it is possible that there were some
forms of human sacrifice performed in
this region but not at all to the extent
that some have claimed and any claims
that sawin means the Lord of death which
is a common claim in some circles and
that therefore Halloween has its origins
in worshiping a demon by this particular
name these reports or these claims are
simply false entirely made up
essentially during the 19th century and
yet this theory is still used by many to
criticize the celebration of Halloween
today so that is possibly the oldest
history of Halloween
that it somehow originated with the
Celtic Festival of sawin and while some
dispute this claim it seems pretty
likely even though the history is much
more complicated too as we will see Lisa
Morton argues that quote although
historians have argued over how much
saign really contributed to the modern
celebration of Halloween it seems likely
that the Celtic festival's peculiar mix
of harvest Rowdy celebration and fearful
Supernatural beliefs gave Halloween much
of its
character but that is only the beginning
of the story after all because during
the Middle Ages Christianity gradually
made its way into Europe and into the um
to the to the Celtic regions as well and
as Christianity became more dominant of
a religion uh local Customs were of
course Very Much affected by this they
were changed and modified but something
really interesting happened especially
at this time with how the Christians
chose to convert the people and to to um
tackle these local Customs because they
were rarely eliminated completely and
this was partly thanks to the church
itself you see the church very quickly
realized that it was much easier to
convert the population if uh already
existing local Customs rather than being
completely eliminated and
just destroyed that they were um
appropriated in different ways that they
were kept in a certain sense but were
often given new Christian clothing this
is a process often known as syncretism
instead of eliminating local Customs you
give it a Christian character so that
there is still a level of familiarity to
the the the local population but now
with a new character that fits the
Christian Theology and Christian
religion old pagan gods could could be
replaced by Catholic saints and
celebrations were rebranded in Christian
ways and in the 8th Century Pope Gregory
III decided to move the celebration of
the martyrs and Saints to November 1st
conveniently right at the same time as
the Festival of
sovn this new holiday which became known
as All Saints Day became widely
celebrated across Europe especially in
Western Europe and still is to this day
around the of the first Millennium
another connected celebration All Souls
day was added on November 2nd which had
the purpose of remembering all the
deceased souls and at that point the
whole old custom of sawin had been
basically replaced by the new Catholic
festivals although many of the old
features of the Festival of course
remained in some form for example the
general theme of death and the afterlife
and it is indeed from this context that
Halloween and the Very name Halloween
comes from
it's an abbreviated version of the name
all Hallow's Eve hallow being an old
word referring to a saint or something
saintly or sacred thus making all
Hallow's Eve a designation of the Eve or
night before All Saints Day and already
by the 1400s and maybe earlier we start
seeing sources indicating that Halloween
was being celebrated as a thing of its
own so to say while of course being
intimately connected with and part of
you could say the larger All Saints Day
and All Souls Day
Celebrations during Halloween people
would prepare certain kinds of food and
it was customary to ring the bells to
inaugurate the holiday in the 17th and
18th centuries we have plenty of sources
talking about Halloween celebrations in
the British Isles and the characteristic
practices that are associated with it
one common aspect of this holiday was
the lighting of bonfires in different
ways this could partly have practical
purposes of Simply getting rid of excess
from the year's Harvest but would also
often have more symbolic functions the
fires were sometimes start to ward off
witches fairies and other evil spirits
that could roam the land on this night
in particular maybe as a survival of
this idea that um on this particular
night the the the the boundary between
this world and the next Were Somehow
opened um or or blurred so that beings
from that other World more easily could
could sort of walk over into this
reality during this night this seems to
have sort of survived even into these
Christian Halloween celebrations another
common theme for Halloween were
different forms of fortune telling since
the beginning Halloween seems to have
been particularly associated with young
people as many at this time would do
different forms of fortune telling and
divination to find out who their future
spouse would be one popular way of doing
this was to to burn nuts different nuts
representing different possible people
would be thrown in the fire and the nut
that burned the brightest and longest
would indicate that future spouse the
poet John gay mentions the custom in one
of his poems quote two hazel nuts I
threw into the flame and to each nut I
gave a Sweetheart's name another popular
practice involved a mirror and an apple
a recurring fruit throughout the history
of Halloween here a young woman would
stand in front of a mirror with an apple
on Halloween and while eating it in
front of this mirror would eventually
see the face of her future
lover Lisa Morton reports that some of
these practices would sometimes have
frightening results as a Lady Jane wild
tells in the ancient legends Mystic
charms and superstitions of Ireland from
1888 quote a lady narrates that on the
1st of November her servant rushed into
the room and fainted on the floor on
recovering she said that she had played
a trick that night in the name of the
devil before the Looking Glass but what
she had seen she dared not speak of
though the remembrance of it would never
leave her brain and she knew the shock
would kill her they tried to laugh her
out of her fears but the next night she
was found quite Dead with her features
horribly contorted lying on the floor
before the Looking Glass which was
shivered to Pieces spooky stuff other
games and pastimes such as apple bobbing
which is still associated with Halloween
today seems to have been a part of the
holiday even back in those days and in
general in these accounts from around
the 18th century it becomes clear that
the holiday was also associated with
what we could call spooky stuff there
are stories of fairies kidnapping people
on Halloween night of witches hiding in
the landscape and terrorizing people but
where indeed did these scary aspects of
Halloween come from how did a holiday
associated with remembering the Catholic
saints and the diseased turn into a
spook Fest associated with spirits and
witches well partly as we saw it's
probably a remnant of the old sawin
Festival where these features seems to
have been pretty prominent many of these
associations and folk practices probably
survived in different ways across the
centuries but this also come
surprisingly from within Christianity
itself and specifically as a result of
the Protestant
Reformation the whole idea of saints was
kind of rejected in the Protestant
churches and therefore there wasn't
really any place for a celebration like
All Saints Day we thus see how there's a
kind of campaign by Protestant Kings
such as Henry VII and James I in the 16
Century to get rid of this popular
holiday this was in the middle of the
witch craze that was infecting Europe
Hinrich Kramers malus maleficarum or the
hammer of witches among other things had
set in motion a hysteria about witches
and the beginnings of the very dark
period in European history that we call
the witch trials in the midst of all
this there was a massive witch trial in
1590 where King James I accused a bunch
of people of being witches and of
gathering on Halloween night in
particular to essentially curse him and
these developments is what started the
strong Association of witches or dark
Forces with Halloween as part of a kind
of campaign to discredit What was seen
as an essentially Catholic holiday and
lucky us right because that's after all
what gives Halloween its spooky and cozy
atmosphere and aesthetic that we all
know and loves so much but so far when
we look at this holiday we while we can
recognize many features of Halloween
many of the most characteristic aspects
of Halloween isn't really there yet uh
where is the Jackal Lantern uh where is
chick or treating when did these
Traditions come about well while we
don't see any direct examples of this in
the earlier periods there are actually
some precursors you could say to it even
back then in terms of trick-or-treating
that popular Pastime for children during
Halloween of walking around in costumes
from house to house asking for candy we
do find a few different practices that
remind us of trick-or-treating in
earlier centuries Not only was it common
for young people around this time to go
around to different houses at asking for
firewood for the large bonfires we also
have stories of people in the Shetland
Islands close to Scotland that would
dress up in costumes and visit houses in
Halloween to ask for food and drink or
these so-called straw Boys in Ireland
which would also go around dressed in
specific costumes and vandalizing in
different ways but the most striking
precursor to trick-or-treating is
probably something that was called soing
there was a particular food item
associated with Halloween which was
called the Soul cake and which was very
popular and soing was a practice when
children and sometimes adults would walk
around dressed up and walk from house to
house asking for soul cake while often
singing a Carol in in sort of payment
you could say sometimes also with
instrumental accompaniment this practice
is indeed very old maybe dating back to
at least the
1500s and one description from the 19th
century says quote the children go
around to the houses early and late on
All Saints Day not on All Souls day and
sing monotonously as dogal the lines
vary little with groups of children
three to six in a group the most
complete version I can give you is as
follows soul soul a soul cake Good
Mistress give us a soul cake one for
Peter one for Paul and one for them as
made us all an apple or a cherry or
anything else to make is Merry Oh Good
Mistress to the seller and fetch us a
pale of water it is a good Fame to get a
good name particularly on the aisle of
man soing often involved the children
carrying with them a carved turnip that
was lit with candles in other words
possibly the precursor to the Jacko
Lantern except it wasn't pumpkins that
were used back then but while the
traditional Halloween celebrations were
centered on the British Isles it was
during the 20th century and in America
that Halloween would arguably take on
the form that it has today indeed
Halloween had actually faded from
popularity pretty drastically uh in in
the sort of native countries in the in
the old country in in the British Isles
and in England and Scotland and Ireland
and so on uh By the 19th century it had
basically almost faded to
obscurity very few people at that point
celebrated Halloween but in America
things were very different in some ways
you could could say that it is in
America that modern Halloween is born
and
develops a lot of the Aesthetics come
from this context including of course
the most famous symbol associated with
Halloween the Jacko Lantern as we saw
earlier there was some precursors to
this in Europe but in that context it
was usually turnips that were used as
lanterns for the kids going around but
it was in the new world that the pumpkin
was to take on this role as the primary
mascot of
Halloween The Jackal Lantern is often
connected to a famous Irish story about
the famous Stingy Jack there are a few
different versions of Stingy Jack's
story but in all of them he somehow
tricks the devil in one he meets the
devil and realizes that it is his time
to die but he then tricks the Devil by
asking for a last drink at the pub and
then for the devil to turn into a coin
in order for him to pay for it after
which he then traps him in the form of
this coin whatever the case Jack always
outwits the devil and as a result when
he eventually actually dies he ends up
in a strange predicament he can't end up
in either heaven or hell so he's cursed
to wander the Earth as a ghost with the
only thing to light his dark path being
a carved out turnip with an ember that
functions as a kind of lantern in
America the turnip was replaced by
pumpkins since these were local growing
squash and eventually
this became a very popular decoration
and symbol during Halloween pumpkins
will be carved out the top part is taken
off and the insides are hollowed out to
fill with a candle it's also customary
to carve a face onto the pumpkin to
truly make it into a Jacko Lantern thus
was born the mascot of Halloween and the
general color scheme of the whole
holiday orange and black orange because
of Jackal lanterns and black because of
the holiday soci association with dark
themes and death and nighttime for
example and it's also in America that
that other staple of Halloween develops
trick-or-treating as we saw there are a
few similar practices that we find in
earlier celebrations in Europe around
Halloween time but it's not certain that
there's a direct connection here there
could be for sure but it's also quite
possible and maybe likely that
trick-or-treating developed
independently in America during the 20
th
Century this was the main practice of
Halloween during that century and thus
the holiday was primarily associated
with children and practiced by them so
to say the only role of the adults was
to be the ones giving out the candy to
the children CH or-treating and thus
Halloween became very popular and
arguably reached its peak in the 1950s
but it is a practice that is still very
much popular in the Life today both in
America and in other parts of the world
as Halloween has in a really interesting
way spread back into Europe where this
holiday had essentially been abandoned
for a long time but Halloween isn't just
for kids of course especially from the
1970s and 1980s with a growing interest
in things like horror movies and what is
sometimes referred to as Monster culture
the classic monster movies of the 1930s
and 40s such as Dracula Frankenstein and
the mummy and the Wolf Man became
associated with Halloween and
incorporated into that aesthetic
Halloween had always been a night when
the kids could you know for one night of
the year stay up late and do things that
were a little more mischievous than on
regular days and out of forbidden
excitement in a certain way and the
holiday kind of took on a similar role
as became more popular with adults too
it was a time of celebrating and
indulging in dark culture in horror and
in the maab in a general sense and on a
psychological level this is very much
what Halloween is about too it's an
opportunity to contemplate and approach
the darker aspects of life such as death
and evil in a way that is focused
contained and often light-hearted and
entertaining it's a time when we can
face Darkness rather than ignore it
which is pretty healthy after all in any
case especially since the 1980s
Halloween has also become a season very
much associated with certain aspects of
Pop Culture such as like we said horror
movies and the Aesthetics that come with
it this maturation of the holiday and
its transition away from children to
more adult themes is perhaps most
clearly sealed with the release of John
Carpenter's classic horror film
Halloween from
1978 where the psychotic killer Michael
Myers goes on a killing spree on
Halloween night wearing a William
Shatner mask Halloween has become one of
the great Classics of horror Cinema and
kind of invented or at least popularized
the slasher film and today all of this
plays a role in Halloween
celebrations from being originally a
European holiday primarily celebrated on
the British Isles Halloween was very
much reborn raised from the dead so to
say in America and has in its American
form and in the last few decades become
popular all across the world it's
celebrated in Japan in Sweden and in
many other places across the world and
when we look at this wonderful season
and the way that it is celebrated we can
see that all of the things that we have
talked about today play a role in its
character and its
features it isn't as simple as just
saying that Halloween is a pagan
festival or that is directly related to
sawin neither can it simply be said that
it is a Christian holiday either all of
these features have played a role in
Halloween it did probably originate in
some way in the ancient Pagan Festival
of sawin and it retains some
characteristics from those roots such as
the association with death and spirits
and its General rowdiness at the same
time perhaps most of the more concrete
aspects of the celebration come more so
from the Catholic Heritage of All Saints
and All Souls day as well as unique
Halloween features that developed in
Christian Europe in the late medieval
and early modern period at the same time
much of modern Halloween is also
strongly connected to different kinds of
Pop culture especially as it developed
in the United States from the gothic
aesthetic and literature such as Dracula
and Frankenstein to witches Ghouls and
ghosts classic horror movies and haunted
house attractions it has all contributed
to the shaping of Halloween as we know
it today it is in other words a
combination of all these historical and
contemporary aspects and perhaps above
all it's simply a lot of fun it's fun to
immerse yourself in the dark atmosphere
of the season to watch all those great
spooky movies and watch your favorite
YouTuber make content about vampires and
Halloween there is something about the
atmosphere and vibe that just attracts a
lot of people and possibly related to
this it is also like we said an
opportunity for us to encounter and
approach those darker yet very real
aspects of our lives and face them if
only for a short period of the Year I
hope you're enjoying the spooky season I
know I am uh
making these shocktober videos is one of
my favorite things to do on this channel
and I know a lot of you in the audience
also really enjoy it so um it's been so
much fun this year as always and I hope
you've enjoyed it happy Halloween
everyone I hope you're careful out there
however you choose to celebrate and that
you're having fun in some way um if
rather you prefer to celebrate the the
old Festival of sawin then I wish you a
meaningful and wonderful Sinn and if
it's just a regular Tuesday or just
regular day I hope that day still is
filled with light and love and meaning
um thank you all for watching this video
thank you all for tuning in for this
year's shocktober uh look forward to
more regular content on the channel
going
forward and I'll see you next
time